Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
So, today's Maestro Hook.
Now remember, the Hook is a good conversation piece...
...that you can use with people when you're talking,...
...when you run out of topics, or you need a good topic to talk about.
So, today is about the Western cultures of surprises.
Western people love surprises...
...whether it's playing a joke or whether it's a surprise party.
When you think about it,...
...in Japanese, there is no direct translation for the word "surprise party."
It's in katakana, right?
So also, Western people love to play jokes on people.
They make a quick remark that's really funny...
...and you need a good response to come back.
So today, I'm gonna teach you something like that.
You had me going.
Oh! You had me going.
And next,...
You take me for a fool?
Oh, come on! You take me for a fool?
Now, the Maestro Lines.
Hey! I'm gonna go back to America and never come back to Japan.
Really?
No, just kidding.
Oh! You had me going.
And the next one.
What is that?
Oh! That's a rock.
We eat rocks in this country.
Oh, come on! You take me for a fool?
Alright. There'll be more topics next week and hope to see you again.
See you later and this was Native Maestro.
See you later!